welcome everybody i'm alexander rose i'm
the executive director at the long now
foundation and welcome to the marathon
relay long conversation i'd like to
thank the contemporary jewish museum for
hosting this and across the way we have
Yerba Buena Center for the Arts hosting
gem Finers long-player live which you'll
be hearing from gem shortly and other
than that on your program there is one
change Danny Hillis got sick today and
was not able to fly so Emily Levine
amazing comedian who has performed
several times that Ted will be filling
in for him and other than that I am
going to set this going every 19 minutes
there will be a new speaker rotating on
you're welcome to stay as long as you
like you're also welcome to wander
across the street the same ticket gets
you in to the long player live piece and
then in the lobby is so so limited is
remix in all the text data video that's
coming out of this in real time and it's
really awesome not to be missed so on
your way out or feel free to hang out
and you can listen to the talks there as
well begin thank you
I am Stuart brand from the long now
foundation what do you see your from Jim
um well in this context I'm from I'm
well I'm part of long player I composed
long player if that's the word for it
and that's the context I'm here in how
long ago did long player start and why
well the the music itself started in on
the cusp of the year 2000 the
International Dateline how long had you
been thinking about it before that cusp
I've been thinking about the idea of
making something they're engaged with
time as a long slow process for a long
time I don't know how many years but
maybe since I was like well not since I
was a kid but since I sort of started
making music and art
and but the idea sort of crystallized
around the middle of the 1990s just
about the time actually we crystallized
10,000 year o'clock I think that's right
something was in the air yeah well I
think what was in the air was the the
millennium approaching right and and for
me something you know I remembered being
a kid so I was born in 1955 and I guess
so around 1960 I can remember my father
giving me comics for the first time or
maybe a bit younger and there were these
science fiction stories about the future
and stuff and the year 2000 seemed to
always you know it was this thing that
was a very long way away and and I can
remember in the in the mid-1990s that in
in England at least in the press people
started to talk about the millennium and
the year 2000 but not beyond it they
were just talking about a few days of
having a party or you know making some
architectural monstrosity to celebrate
it but nothing beyond the only thing I
could find that was thinking beyond 2000
was the World Cup in 2002 that seemed to
be the only you know the only forward
thinking going on so that sort of
crystallized my thinking about so cycles
let you punch through membranes like the
year 2000 cycles like World Cup coming
around every so often and well it seems
to be yeah I mean that's the only thing
that people seem to talk about in the
press that was beyond 2000 now you
mentioned as we were assembling here
that you intersected with Brian Eno and
Brian Eno's one of the board members and
founding people really yeah now
foundation connected you with the idea
of long now o'clock various things how
did that play out well one when I had
the idea of making long player this long
piece of something I thought well a
piece of music is a way to go and
I approached a friend an acquaintance
really that my wife Marcia prompted me
to go and talk to Michael Morris who's
the director of an organization called
art angel in London they commissioned
art works of an unusual nature and he he
was very interested and he said well
would you like us to Commission you and
I said yeah that would be great so I
really landed on my feet and and he's a
friend of Brian's and one of the first
things we did was we should have made we
called them think tanks which was
inviting a group of people to you know
as I had ideas and worked my way through
them we'd all sit down and spend an
evening talking and so Brian was one of
the people invited and and he came along
and was incredibly helpful about you
know pointing me in various directions
and I learnt having started working on
long-player I read his book called a
year with swollen appendices and in one
of the pink appendices I found a
one-page piece of writing about the long
now foundation the clock and and I was
really excited about this I thought this
amazing this that you know same kind of
motivations in a different way of
approaching it and then obviously a more
ambitious timescale I have only ten
times more ambitious than yours yeah I
know yeah well you're Americans
so you're realist well actually you know
people say to me long players a
thousand-year piece of music what
happens at the end and I say well
actually it's an everlasting piece of
music that repeats every thousand years
so it's a kind of more like a planetary
system that came to the same point at
now because the ten thousand year
o'clock people say what happens in
you're 8,000 yeah and nothing specialist
yeah 10,000 in the middle of the time
frame that we're trying to manage into
but it's also easier to say just as a
thousand is easier to say since we're on
the decimal system
exactly I suppose if we are totally
binary we'd come up with some other fun
though well if we're totally binary
you'd have a millennium every eight
years I mean that's one of the things I
thought was absurd about this whole
thousand thing you know it's like
because we've got these wobbly things on
the end of our hands yeah well it's the
clock by the way it was not decimal and
in fact the clock works because it is
binary you had who's the fellow in
England who made a map [ __ ] Babbage
made a fabulous computer ever so long
ago previous century before the last one
and one of the reasons it didn't work is
because it was decimal rather than
binary that's right and and the guys
here say it's also because Babbage did
not have FedEx well that's probably got
a lot to do that yeah FedEx
I prefer UPS actually have nicer
uniforms and your piece of music is very
time drenched in a way because many
aspects of it presumably could not have
been done in a previous century and a
century from now the kind of
instrumentation you're using will seem
very archaic won't it well it's funny
you should say that because when I
started working on it I just assumed
very naturally I'd use a computer hmm
because obviously to literally write
10,000 years with the music's out of the
question really so you know I always
took you for granted I'd work find out
I'd work out some process which would
generate that on school but a place
where Brian Eno is very helpful and
Danny Hillis by proxy so I think and the
whole clock of the long now
sort of idea of how to do things was
that Brian kept saying you can't just do
this on a computer you know and I was
beginning so saying why not you know
like there'll be someone that's a
caretaker of this and you know when the
computer breaks down they can just go
and buy a new one and he said yeah well
you know the operating systems change
how do you know you know they'll be
computers and I kind of was in denial
for a while because I was too obsessed
with well how they had am I going to do
this and and once I hit on a system I
thought hang on this is pointless unless
it actually can find form in any
technology mm-hmm
fortunately the system I came up with
was one that lend itself to mechanical
reproduction being played by human
beings
it wasn't tied to a computer the
computer wasn't doing anything
the only computers can do as it were so
this is basically a score that goes
forth oh yeah yeah so and there's it in
some sense algorithmic that it's playing
out some formula yeah it's totally
deterministic you could sit down and
write it out as notation conventional
notation mm-hm and it can be played on
acoustic instruments that's why it ended
up using the singing bowls well for a
number of reasons but one being that you
know they're resilient sturdy and things
that will hold their tuning for a long
time there's other reasons too but you
know cultural and to do with acoustics
but so in fact having I call it post
digital because it's something that
started out through thinking in
processes and ways that one learns to
think of when you computer programming
but it kind of breaks through that back
into
tactile relationship with the world so
it's like returning to attacked our
relationship with materials instruments
the world but informed by strategies one
learns from programming computers and so
the form it ended up with is actually
something that if I'd thought about in a
different way to start with I might have
arrived that without a computer and so
what what the live version has been
boiled down to is something that relies
on no technology at all the only bit of
vague technology that's there is the
stopwatches people used to time
themselves which a clockwork yes not so
vague yeah that's pretty crisp like we
have 8 minutes and 36 seconds yet just
be here so at the Brian Eno story I was
at I forget if he buries it but we were
talking about chains ringing yeah the
strange British behavior of going out
and basically playing the bells in
churches all night long according to
some mathematical algorithms they have
wonderful names of the various ways it's
played and Brian of course because he
was doing music ambient music and so on
that often was kind of playing itself in
a certain fashion in a similar way got
in touch with the change ringers
Association or whatever it is I'm sure
wonderfully quits a quixotic group and
got in touch with him said I'd like to
know how you do your music and he got a
very stern letter back saying it's not
music is that right that's right and he
was both chastened and felt sorry for
them because as far as he was going but
from their standpoint the the rigour of
playing out their ferocious mathematical
ferocity of you know getting through the
entire sequence getting through it right
all night long and you know until it
comes all the way around that kind
thing do you relate to the change
ringing tradition at all definitely yeah
also yeah I think it's a it's a really
interesting algorithmic form of making
music and I find that fascinating they
don't recognize it you ever seen it up
close people up in the belfry you know
rising up on these I've seen films I
haven't actually seen them in person but
I mean I've been in bell towers I've
seen those bells most recently in birth
and they're like massive bells mm-hmm
yeah I mean a bunch of people standing
around the circle all just grim as hell
gazing at one another you know it's
because they've got to get this equal is
that one there is that one there was now
the matter with me and and the there's
this weird delay because they pull on
the the bell rope and nothing happens
and then lag after dong they've done it
must be nerve-racking
it's very perilous I believe you can
have a nasty accident well if you don't
let go you get taken right up and then
die and then that's destroyed it's the
sequence and everybody's mad at you yeah
exactly
plus there was a wonderful mystery what
was the name of it that's based around
change ringing say it again 90 lers
right it was in 90s was the name of one
of the the the ringings right Dorothy
Sayers there you go
crowdsourcing can happen anywhere so
here we are you've thought about long
now long announced thought about you now
we're intersecting yeah are we gonna do
this every thousand years or what do you
think what's the what happens when these
two long pieces of our intersect well
each other the audience or permission or
increase matter we cancel each other out
what happens now I don't think we can
see each other out right and I'm very
I'm glad that there's I think they're
really two very interesting ways of
approach
the same problems because a clock is one
way of thinking about time and piece of
music it's a very different way of
thinking about time because in a piece
of music you need a clock well you don't
need to clock you can play totally out
of time but the way long player plays
you you need you need a clock to play it
and all computers so far indeed clocks
at something a long time but there's
like there's lots of different time
scales going on within it and the
experience of playing musics one which
is very I mean through playing music I
became aware of Thai experiencing time
and very different way of from before I
played music because when you're playing
music live mm-hmm you get a very strong
feeling you're sort of surfing on the
edge of time if that makes sense it you
really I suppose you're living in the
present very ok yeah you you because
you're with a bunch of other people
often unless you're solo you're all on
the same beat yeah and that's
astonishing in a way is that we're all
of this strict time I mean that's the
overlap so far as well time as implies a
lot in music sorry time epsom flows a
lot as you I'm sure you know do you play
music subjective time absent flow
subjective time yeah okay what about
astronomy because the the thing that we
found is is with the clock very quickly
once we got larger than hours days start
to be an astronomical event ears or
earth an astronomical event and by and
by we're talking about the precession of
the equinoxes every twenty six thousand
eight hundred and thirty two or whatever
it is years yeah and that's sort of fun
but we're we're finding that we're doing
this arbitrary thing with seconds maybe
dating back to early Persians but pretty
quick
you get from arbitrary into what's
already there
and I suppose especially physical music
which is dealing a physical things
singing bells or whatever your your your
making a deal with physical reality
bashing your imagination up against
physical reality and then trying to go
from your subjectivity into the
listeners subjectivity via that process
that's pretty strange I guess I mean
it's not language is it no it's not
language at all but I mean I mean I
think that's one of the reasons I wanted
to make something that dealt with time
in these ways is because I couldn't
understand it you know it's like a
curiosity like I mean since I've a kid I
was maybe I've got one of these
conditions you know that I need to know
how things work mm-hmm so I'd always
take things apart and couldn't ever put
them back together again clocks and toys
anything I could get apart and untime
it's just another of those things it's
like a curiosity how does this work how
do I experience it like this how does it
what does it mean in terms of cosmology
philosophy etc and language I couldn't
do it language I think this is one of
the reasons I was compelled to mm-hmm
do it with some kind of art well you're
also safe and then the language is
likely to move all many long distances
in a thousand years whereas what you're
doing with music can be much the same it
occurs to me as you were thinking about
doing this piece of music you must had
some ideas about and we're kind of
learning about that process of taking it
seriously then you actually did it
starting in 2000 and some things must
have occurred that well that's
interesting and surprising now what and
here we are ten years later and you're
doing it again you know are what are the
realizations for you as the player and
that you see in the listeners as you
move along and we have one minute left
to you say this I don't know if I can
say that in one minute well just to say
it very quickly it's like it when
long-player started
beginning of 2000 I thought that's great
I've done it but actually that was just
the beginning and I just keep learning
things from it and it evolved 'z in the
sea your hold sorry how old are you
fifty-five okay so you get another 30 or
40 years of learning from this piece oh
yeah thanks very much nice nice to talk
to you and I have 15 seconds to say I
will be back at the end of this long
cycle that's a long cycle and meanwhile
the next speaker is out greeting us all
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]